it's a nice fashion fix lady gaga's  designer and stylist gives our Josie the  secrets to her style she never walks  into a room and thinks that she is like  up here and someone's down here neveress  Branden Maxwell is the man behind Gaga's  three Oscar looks and the collared  menswear inspired performance outfit had  to be just perfect it's so personal to  her that song and it's so personal to so  many different people so I really wanted  to be respectful and so did she  Gaga made a pact with her fellow sexual  assault survivors one girl said I really  want to get matching tattoos the 30 year  old Maxwell from Texas now has his own  fashion brand first out he created a  fourth Oscar dress has she won what was  the look that was left behind um that  was actually a look from the show we did  a black velvet strapless mini dress  little peplum on the side and for her we  did it in a sort of celery velvet that  was a long gown